[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le coût réel
andréanne pour regarder un petit peu
combien ont coûté nos produits en les
produits sanitaires notamment mme amazon
qui est accusé d'avoir gonflé les prix
de certains produits très en demande
depuis le début de la crise
je vais vous ramenez gérald fin mars
mois d'avril c'est à peu près où nos
repas je sais que vous voulez pas venir
pour vous remémorer à quel point c'était
difficile de trouver des masques du gel
hydroalcoolique les stocks étaient à sec
est ce qu'on trouvait en ligne c'était
des prix astronomiques et on avait
reproché à amazon d'avoir des produits à
des prix un peu déraisonnable sur son
site avait rejeté amazon la faute sur
les revendeurs de cce qui font grimper
les prix et une aujourd'hui d'un
organisation américaine s'appelle public
c'était une organisation de défense des
droits des consommateurs qui dit
attention on a trouvé des preuves qu
amazon elle-même a augmenté les prix de
ses produits sur sa propre plateforme
exemple paquet 50 masques jetables le
prix maximum auquel on a vendu 100 entre
février et où sur la plateforme
d'amazon.com 40 $ on pouvait trouver ça
à 4 dollars avant la pandémie tout 1000
% d'augmentation savons antibactériens
augmentation 2 470% gages aux tables
336% plus cher qu'avant la pandémie est
pas finie j'ai d'autres exemples gel
hydroalcoolique augmentation de 48%
la farine général salue un clive oui 80
dollars on se pose quand même des
questions sur qui a acheté ça à ce prix
mais c'est une augmentation phénoménale
même chose pour le sucre 520 pour ça
alors ça disons que amazon on a
peut-être profiter dans certains cas
mais comment amazon explique ça en fait
dit qu'on n'a pas intentionnellement
voulu profiter des besoins des
consommateurs en temps de pandémie que
ses propres coûts d'approvisionnement
ont grimpé rejette la faute sur les
revendeurs c'est vrai qu'ils ont une
responsabilité d'avoir entraîné une
hausse moyenne des prix eux aussi j'ai
le droit que les connotations de 400%
savons antibactériens 274% bref tout
laitière sur la plateforme
amazon donc qui dit que s'il ya eu des
erreurs il s'en excuse ça a été corrigée
rapidement
désolé mais aussi android